the goal of geoengineering is basically
a technological way of dealing with
global warming from increasing
greenhouse gas emissions so that could
be by either reducing carbon dioxide
concentrations directly dealing with the
problem or by doing something more than
you like reducing the amount of solar
energy coming into the earth and cooling
the client that way yeah we know there
are a number of proposals for different
geoengineering options : caption caption
storage is the obvious one because it
removes co2 carbon dioxide removal is
fundamentally dealing with what's
causing the problem but the disadvantage
is slow it did you know that the rate at
which you can draw down carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere is quite slow and
it's probably gonna be very expensive I
would put these artificial trees in to
absorb the co2 that is saved you
engineering if you can extract co2 from
the atmosphere using some sort of
machine that acts as an artificial tree
that doesn't have a downside I think it
needs to be in the discussions around
the the negotiation negotiations will be
about the line go long because they
always are and they've been you know
they've been prepared over the last
since a lot of cotton eating really so
they will be about that but I hope
there's a tendency now for some policy
basic hold on a minute is there
something else we could do I mean is
that it you know some people are saying
this is really excited it's like a
moonshot challenge could we could
humanity actually work how to remove co2
from there so that we can we can get
avoid this 2 degree target and still and
still make transitions to our economies
that are sustainable so the that's the
reason why people are thinking about
this solar reflection method is that you
can basically achieve a very very rapid
and potentially quite big cooling and
very short space of time and the
consensus is it's probably gonna be
quite cheap so or doesn't mean cheap is
a relative term here but we're talking
billions of dollars maybe tens of
billions
so basically the cost of I know
government health care programs large
government healthcare programs is
similar to the cost of solar radiation
management geoengineering and that's
certainly cheaper than mitigation by
reducing greenhouse gas emissions and
changing your energy systems I wouldn't
want the solar radiation management
geoengineering to be seen as an option
right now it's almost like an emergency
measure and it's scientifically very
interesting and there are some things
about it that from a purely scientific
perspective make a lot of sense but the
problem with that
SRM G Engineering is it's a long term
commitment if you don't cut the co2 then
you have to maintain this this
brightness shield for indefinitely and
there's we've not been very good at
doing things sustainably I mean what we
do is we change things
sort of beyond recognition but we don't
generally say right we're going to
commit to this for the next three
generations so if you're going to do
this so radiation management I think
would have to be a short-term thing and
it's more like an emergency measure the
removing co2 from the air which is in
some ways is is more palatable to people
just you know take it out I mean the
most obvious where it is is growing
forests turns out not to be a very
efficient way to strangely trees are not
and not evolved specifically to take co2
earlier they've evolved to reproduce and
survive but actually taking co2 in the
air ism is a safer thing to do the
storage problems big because we've
emitted so much fossil fuels you'd have
to find ways to bury it safely but so I
would say we should front up to the fact
that that the scenarios that avoid two
degrees have so-called negative
emissions which implies this carbon
dioxide removal to engineering there are
scientists that are talking about SRM
and what it would mean but very few of
them would say let's do it they would
say send me funding so I can think about
it but at the end of they mosters would
say I hope it doesn't come to this so
there's an awful lot of non kind of
non-technical non-scientific issues at
solar radiation
mostly to do with control and you think
about this it's a cheap technology that
can be done by not need you don't even
have to be a kind of first world rich
country to do this you don't even need
to be a country you could be a rich
corporation you could do it because it's
sufficiently cheap so there are issues
of control to do a thorough radiation
management what it gives us is basically
the power to to some extent tune the
temperature of the earth to to a
particular level and the preferred level
is definitely not the same for different
people and so maybe if you're Russia you
want it to be a bit warmer you want
Siberia to become a more productive area
for growing your crops
whereas if you live in the tropics you
probably don't want it to be warmer and
you want to you want control of the
climate thermostat to enhance the
cooling more and get a cooler climate so
the geopolitical implications of solar
radiation management probably trump
anything that science and technology can
kind of offer us in a way of saying it's
a good idea because there are so many
fundamental issues with it that it might
be a non-starter regardless of our
technological capabilities so I think at
this stage we probably shouldn't be we
shouldn't be thinking about it as a
frontline measure to combat climate
change in the kind of council the
parties conferences but people do really
need to be thinking about that people
are listening there's loads of people
thought cleverer than me thinking about
this thinking about the geopolitical
implications of geoengineering whether
it's covered by existing treaties
international treaties and things like
that